У ювелірки Шандри та її чоловіка-програміста Петера
вже є одна дитина. Невдовзі подружжя планує
завести ще двох дітей, адже від початку 2019-го
уряд Угорщини усіляко це заохочує. Наприклад,
надає так званий "материнський капітал"
у розмірі 31 тисячі євро. Це безвідсоткова позика.
У разі появи другої дитини сума, яку треба
повернути державі, зменшуєтсья із 31 тисячі євро
до всього лише 10 тисяч. І це ще далеко не все.
Шандра й Петер у захваті.
- Завдяки урядовій допомозі ми змогли придбати
цю квартиру. Інакше б і досі винаймали житло.
А торік ми отримали додаткові 30 тисяч євро
урядової допомоги, яку могли витрачати
на що завгодно. А якщо у вас троє дітей, то ці гроші
зовсім не треба повертати.
Утім, є в урядової програми й критики.
Це демонстрація під вікнами одного з них.
Мер сьомого району Будапешта Петер Нідермюллер
заявляє, що "золотий дощ" для родин від прем'єра Орбана -
насправді дискримінаційний. Адже програма
призначена для молодих, білих, гетеросексуальних
родин християнського віросповідання. Крім того,
програма не така соціальна, як здається.
- Ця родинна політика працює для добре освіченого
молодого середнього класу. Якщо, наприклад, у вас
родина з 4 дітей, то ви можете купити великий
автомобіль для всієї родини. Держава готова
покрити до 50% коштів. Але якщо у вас немає
стартової суми грошей, то цієї можливості ви позбавлені.
Факти свідчать, що урядовий план підтримки родин
наразі не приніс бажаних результатів.
Кількість одружень і справді зросла на 50%
після запровадження стимулів,
однак народжуваність залишається незадовільною.
Якщо десять років тому на кожну жінку в Угорщині
припадало в середньому 1,23 дитини, то торік
цей показник становив 1,49. Населення продовжує
зменшуватися. Втім, багато угорців вірять, що уряд -
на правильному шляху. Потрібно лише більше часу.
- Якщо ми не хочемо щезнути як нація, то,
я думаю, важливо допомогти людям ростити дітей.
Програма уряду також підтримує цінності:
християн, європейську культуру. Я гадаю,
цей стиль життя поверне нас до наших витоків.
Як би там не було, прем'єр-міністр Віктор Орбан
від урядової програми підтримки традиційних родин
дивіденди отримав. Його популярність серед угорців
незмінно висока. Вони не хочуть чути аргументи
таких політиків, як Нідермюллер.
(люди співають)
Хор прихильників національної ідеї
та традиційних цінностей в Угорщині перекриває
поодинокі заклики до толерантності та різноманітності в суспільстві.